Who are you staying with right now?
Are you staying with family?
Well, yes, I came,
I came to see my mum.
And my sister who are here.
I'm not actually in
the same house as them.
But yes, I came to see my
mum, my chain smoking mother,
who is assuring me, that
she's protecting herself
from coronavirus with smoking.
Which she read on some
dark web, protects you.
So she she's gone from
smoking a packet a day,
to now she's up to probably two packs,
because she's convinced
it's saving her life.
And she's read somewhere that in France,
they even put nicotine
patches on corona patients,
which I actually believe.
I think it seems very French.
But I'm not sure that she's,
I don't know whether her
theory is true. (laughs)
And I keep saying to her
mum, this is really worrying.
Can you please stop smoking?
And she says, "Darling."
Her answer is, "Darling.
I don't have a dry cough.
"I've got a very fruity cough."
(Conan laughs)
Which indeed, (laughs) indeed she does.
Let me jump in here and just,
all due respect to your mom,
this is terrible advice
for anybody out there.
You do not want to be smoking
and combat coronavirus.
There's no evidence that.
I mean, listen, I don't
wanna get into a fight
with your mom, but she
sounds like the kind
who always wants to be smoking.
Coronavirus, no
coronavirus, is that right?
Yes, She's just upped it.
She's just upped it a lot.
And now she's, she
feels that she's totally
within her rights to close all the doors
and all the windows and, you know,
expose us to sort of second-degree
lung cancer. (laughs)
While she protects her own health
(laughing) by chain smoking.
Now, I know you have kids.
How are your kids doing with
the quarantine in isolation?
Are they okay?
They've been really good.
They've very brave and
much more kind of stoic,
in a way, than anyone else.
But there are the odd
moments of lapses where,
me and my husband were in the,
I think we were upstairs
and they were downstairs
at one point in the midst of it all.
And we heard our daughter, who's 10,
say very loudly to our son, who's 16,
(laughs) "Can you stop farting in my face?
"I'm just trying to survive here!"
(Conan laughs)
which I felt just about
summed up the experience
(laughs) for all of us.
I would prefer your mom's
cigarette smoke, I think.
(laughing) Yeah, exactly.
Starting to look really,
really good to me.